thank you
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast I have the distinct pleasure of
sitting this morning with Mary
Harrington who is contributing editor at
unheard a fantastic publication she is
also the author of a new book that is
soon to emerge called feminism against
progress Mary Welcome To Dark Horse
thank you for having me
well I'm very excited to have this
conversation with you I have been
reading your work for uh several years
now and we are in an interesting
position I don't know how aware you are
of my thinking as discussed with Heather
on our podcast for example and then in
our book 100 gatherers Guide to the 21st
century but you and I agree on a wide
range of topics surrounding the modern
predicament of humans women in
particular the implications of feminism
a lot of topics that many people would
consider difficult to reach agreement on
you and I are there already
but I think we take nearly opposite
lessons from what it is that I believe
we agree on and I'm very much looking
forward to exploring that with you here
as my longtime viewers and listeners
know I don't do interviews I really have
discussions with people and so that's
what we're about to have I uh I hope
you're as excited to explore this
territory as I am there is no more
worrying sign about the state of Western
Civilization than the degradation of our
academic institutions that is why I am
so excited about the sponsor for this
episode Ralston College
Ralston is a new institution of higher
education with Jordan Peterson as its
Chancellor they are currently accepting
applications to their one-year Masters
in the humanities program
that program begins with two months in
Greece with immersion study of ancient
and modern Greek on the island of Samos
with visits to Olympia Delphi Ephesus
and other sites in the ancient world
after Greece students continue their
educational Odyssey in beautiful
Savannah Georgia with a
multi-disciplinary curriculum featuring
philosophy literature art and music
this is a once in a lifetime opportunity
and admissions are open now there are a
number of full and partial scholarships
available
for more information visit ralston.ac
Darkhorse that's
r-a-l-s-t-o-n dot AC
Darkhorse if you're ready to do the hard
thinking our era demands
[Music]
let's do it all right good so do you
want to briefly lay out your position
with respect to uh feminism and what it
has and has not done for women
well in feminism against progress well
there are three parts really to the book
there's the how we got there I mean it's
pretty standard really how we got there
where I where I see us
being now and how how I think we we
might respond to that and it's a fairly
large it's a fairly big picture how we
got here because I wanted to re-read the
history of feminism from outside the
progress frame which is habitually
applied to it I mean if I this all this
all came about because I lost my faith
in progress I stopped believing in it
and came to think that it's a belief
structure you know with with
similarities to to a Theology of in the
book I called it progress Theology and I
I see it straightforwardly as a as a
form of secularized um
a secularized outgrowth of of a still
broadly very Christian culture which is
it's it's taken some of the Christian
eschatology and it's just removed the
Heaven hellbit from it so but otherwise
remains structurally very similar so
it's my it's my view this is a belief
not a fact it's not actually I don't
believe that we're progressing towards
some kind of infinite better
um I don't I don't think we move forward
or move backwards as such it's not
obvious to me that there's any way you
can prove that the aggregate sum of good
or Felicity or however you want to
measure it is is necessarily better now
than it was 2000 years ago so and I
think at the moment you set out to argue
that it is
um you have to you have to Define your
terms at which point you've assumed the
truth of what you set out to prove uh
you've begged the question
so that's that's broad that's that's my
that's the very big picture frame for
where I'm coming from in the book
um which is I don't believe in progress
um this this left me with some
difficulties as a as a nerd who has to
think things all the way through
um because I I found I've I've long
thought of myself as a feminist ever
since I was in my early teens really and
came to came to think that there were
some significant ways in which women's
position left something to be desired
there were things which didn't feel fair
to me still this is still true
um and and so I immersed myself in
feminist Theory and to an extent you
know did my best to embrace feminist
practice
um
now this so when I realized I didn't
believe in progress it left me with
something of a challenge because
feminism or rather the advances made by
what's what we normally think of as the
feminist movement or generally the first
thing anybody will hold up as evidence
that we are in fact progressing and we
can progress you know if I if I say well
I don't believe in progress somebody
will say well you have the vote now Mary
you know you you're no longer you can
own property you can work you know
surely this is progress
um which yes with on its own terms this
is this is a change from what we had
before but if so if I don't believe in
progress look I spent something like 10
years trying to answer the question for
myself really not knowing the answer to
the question is it still possible to be
a feminist if you don't believe in
progress
um and I think it took me the best part
of 10 years to square that Circle and
the point the point I've got to with it
I guess is yes you can but it depends it
depends a bit what you mean by feminism
and it depends a bit what you mean by
progress
um and and so essentially I set out to
to redefine or rather to reread the
women's movement in a way that would
make it make sense without the progress
theology goggles on and where I got to
with that was an understanding of the
women's movement in much more
materialist terms as an as an effect of
the the very real and thoroughgoing
changes which which Spilled Out of the
Industrial Revolution and into family
life and particularly with the departure
of work from the home which was a
radical change from from the largely
agrarian and artisanal Middle Ages where
both both Partners both both men and
women worked albeit in slightly in with
with distinctive roles in but in a
primary economic unit of a productive
household and some variant of this holds
for for most medieval western cultures
because the the the main economic unit
was not an individual as it is today it
was a productive household
and within within those terms minimum
both worked and of course when the
Industrial Revolution came along and a
great deal of that work left the home
and went in and for factories and women
were faced with new conundrums about how
to
how to navigate the carrying on the
caring obligations to children in in
conjunction with or or in Zero Sum
opposition two
um work which now happens somewhere else
and out of this Falls a huge a huge
number of subsidiary issues to do with
to do with the physical protection of
women in industrial workplaces to deal
with a huge number of class inflected
issues how to manage child care you know
and and this and from this emerged the
entirety of the women's movement along
two distinctive tracks which I've set
out in the first part of the book which
I've characterized as the feminism of
freedom and the feminism of care
which interacted fruitfully with one
another in seeking to balance women's
desire for autonomy and participation in
public life
um against women's realistic and
fragment pragmatic recognition of
women's distinctive reproductive role
and also desire to to care for children
under under deep conviction in a great
many cases that this is important and
significant a needed needed political
and legal recognition in a way which
which had been compromised by the
changes of Industrial Revolution
so right so so this is my understanding
of feminism throughout the majority of
its history and it's my contention that
that feminism is now over and has been
and has been dead and gone for 50 years
well you've laid out enough issues there
that we could easily spend the rest of
the podcast and three more like it uh
unpacking them I will say there's one
place already where I I think our
disagreement uh is going to Center
um and I would ask you to step into my
perspective for a moment I'm an
evolutionary biologist
and uh that
creates a certain perspective from which
I view things and while I would agree as
an evolutionary biologist that progress
is very very unlikely what evolution and
in particular selection is is a
mechanism that filters the huge range of
changes that are not positive and sorts
from them the tiny percentage of changes
that are and so while uh you and I would
not disagree over the unlikeliness of
progress we would potentially disagree
over whether or not progress is a
recognizable theme in uh change you know
whether that's the morphological change
within creatures let's say our ancestors
or whether it is the cultural change
that has taken over our uh adaptive
architecture in the last few million
years of human history
so you really mean that you don't
believe in progress as in progress does
not happen or do you mean that you are
so Optical of claims of progress
well but actually what you've just
described whether we're talking about an
evolution of culture or an evolution of
organisms of course I don't dispute that
this that this happens I mean my my
academic study was in English literature
and at the point at the point where I
was most immersed in it I remember
having this this phenomenal moment of
insight into the in the immense sweep of
an evolution of an entire culture
um and the the the the the way that
ideas had morphed into other ideas over
over the course of something like a
thousand years and just having that
Crystal Clear grasp of that that entire
picture and that entire process of
evolution
um so and all of this really just to say
that I absolutely would not dispute I
couldn't be further from disagreeing
with the the idea that that cultures
consciousnesses and organisms evolve
this is absolutely indisputably the case
yeah but I think you'd have to be it'll
be wildly a historical and ignorant to
disagree with that however what I
question is the idea of attributing a
moral value to this
idea that there was something there's
something intrinsically better about how
we are now than say a thousand years ago
well that's like that I do question I
think that's that's not that's that's
that that we can that that's that I
dispute good
um I was I will say I did not mean to
imply that any part of me wondered
whether you doubted the reality of
evolution be it morphological or or
cultural
um interesting that you heard my comment
that way but
um but in any case Okay so it sounds
like
your concern about progress comes in two
forms you are skeptical of
claims of progress and you are doubtful
that to the extent that progress does
happen both morphologically and cultural
culturally that one can ground it uh as
moral in nature in other words that
wasn't said very clearly on my part but
it sounds like you see the two questions
as separate right we can make gains on a
particular you know we can for example
alter our cultural practices we can
start rotating our crops and we can
prove that there's been a greater yield
by rotating them than keeping them in
the same Fields year after year but that
is not the same thing as saying that
this has bettered us that better it is a
fundamentally different sort of claim is
that what you're saying
essentially yes I mean civilizations
civilization growth complexify and then
they rise and they rise and typically
over if history is any kind of a guide
they fall again eventually as well you
know this there isn't I
if if there's a if there's a an immense
teleological Arc to the whole thing it's
beyond my grasp and I think at that
point we're we really are into the realm
of Theology and certainly it's not
something I think we could reasonably
attribute to to the the day-to-day
political events of one one specific
culture here as in the one that we're in
right now interesting all right so if I
were to make
um the counter argument I would say
that to the extent I I agree with you
that we cannot ultimately ground any of
these claims in a
um
fundamentally
moral calculus in other words I I don't
even think we can defend the idea that
being alive is better than being dead it
is only that we are the descendants of
creatures that have an unbroken line of
living and reproducing that stretches
back three and a half billion years that
caused causes us to be uh very uh
substantially cognitively biased in the
direction of thinking that being alive
is better than being dead but there's no
uh there's no ultimate argument for that
uh position that is that is a value
judgment that we impose on a kind of
order
um and uh and we prioritize it over over
disorder over entropy
um but nonetheless if we Grant ourselves
that first move if we say that from the
perspective of creatures that find it
better to be alive than than to be dead
or to be non-living
and
we understand that our you know that we
are in some way by the same sort of
logic better off to be humans with
choice and the capacity to reflect the
capacity to produce
um
novel works that these things have a
similar sort of value
then surely it is
incumbent on us to deliver
that opportunity that is to say a a
meaningfully liberated life to as many
people as we can over the future
right so anyway my claim is that there
is something
that from within our human framework we
could say would constitute progress if
we if we could measure the number of
humans that were living a meaningfully
liberated life and that number were to
go up
in over the indefinite future that that
would constitute a kind of progress
which does not mean that that's the
trajectory we are we are on
does that is that sensible from your
framework
I understand the argument you're making
I'm not I'm I don't find it compelling
though I've got to be honest
um this is not to say I'm a complete
near list but just I don't I don't see
you you dropped meaningfully liberated
in there it felt kind of out of the blue
a little bit
um and I I would want to understand I'd
want you to be a bit more specific about
what that means
um before I could say whether I agree or
not because I think but because I I
question I question
in the book also the centrality of
Liberation as as as pretty much the one
and only value that we've that we have
left to order and what it is that we
understand this progress and I've I've
gone into some yeah I've spent quote
quite a bit of time questioning why why
just that and and suggesting that
perhaps we need to ground that in some
some more meaning more embodied
realities so so I guess I guess I would
say but please say more about uh
meaningfully liberated and and are there
any limits to that and if so why and if
not then I have a few other questions
great well I think you are already
forcing me uh to refine my own position
um so thank you for that what I'm what
I'm getting at is some sort of a
principle where you know you could
compare for example
the success of
ants
to the success of humans and we could
make an argument that the number of ants
on Earth dwarfs the number of humans and
that they are therefore in some ways
more successful
I want to avoid that I would regard that
as uh an argument
uh it's sophistry in some sense but what
I'm what I'm reserving the right to do
and I'm not sure it is philosophically
Justified but my intuition is that it is
is to say from the point of view of
having landed in our human form right
with no belief that the human form is in
it in itself fundamentally better than
any other form but what it is is capable
of a few things that no other creature
can do
and so I regard human specialness
as
precious
and therefore
I suppose I would argue that things that
protect and augment
the specially human capabilities that we
have that is to say the ability to
um reflect to
deliberately pursue objectives rather
than automatically pursue them
and to in fact impose values on an
otherwise cold universe that those
things it's not surprising that I as a
human being would find those things
valuable and that I would see them as
desirable to Foster in the future in the
same way that I find my own homeostasis
into the next hour a desirable thing to
Foster even though I can't really make
an argument that it is desirable in any
ultimate sense
so I mean do you I guess that's the
question do you believe from within your
perspective as a human being that the
you know special
types of insight and compassion and
other things that we find limited to
humans or maybe in some cases humans and
a few other very special creatures do
you find something uh worth preserving
about those characteristics uh yes
absolutely absolutely I guess I would
but where some distance now from
meaningful Liberation in the sense that
I mean if we're if we're talking about
protecting and augmenting human
capabilities which are distinct to us as
people
um I would I would challenge the idea
that Liberation is the only move that
that will that that's necessary in order
to do that I mean really what we're
talking about here is the the entire the
the Gestalt of human nature which my
sense is that you and you know which
which I suspect is probably a concept
that you'd want to drill down into a
little bit and and we can probably have
some fun doing that but let's say there
is such a thing you know the the
distinctive capabilities of a human you
know that that is something I think we
could probably agree on that great and
there are there are those there is a
Gestalt of those attributes all right
and these these have emerged over a
great great deal of time
um via VIA evolutionary processes and
cultural processes and material
processes and so on and we are where we
are in a sense with those and and I
would I would absolutely agree with you
that those are those are things that we
should treasure and protect I suppose I
would question the idea that Liberation
is the only move we need to make in
order to do so and in fact I've in the
book I've set out to make the case that
only Liberation is in if we if we hyper
focus on Liberation underwritten by
technology we will end up making choices
which are inimical to the Gestalt of
those those precious qualities of a
human which we which it's incumbent on
us to protect
beautiful because these are good things
I think I now yeah this is um I I hope
people are able to follow this
conversation because I think we've
actually gotten somewhere pretty
interesting the connection between my
argument for human specialness and uh
meaningful Liberation is that you can
take a human who has all of the
characteristics that make people special
and you can constrain them either
because of privation or because of
authoritarianism you know they could be
born into slavery and unable to
meaningfully act on any of those special
human characteristics and I would regard
that as a squandering of human potential
and so the reason I put meaningful
Liberation in there is not that
meaningful Liberation is sufficient
to bring about the human specialness but
I do believe it is probably necessary
that you be to some extent liberated in
order for your compassion your Insight
your Ingenuity to produce anything that
we could then call progress so I think
that's that's important but then where I
think you and I have landed in agreement
assuming that you would agree with what
I just said is that it tells us that
there is at least a kind of human
progress that is possible that we could
potentially even measure whether we are
making gains on it or losing ground and
that would have something to do with
whether or not people were meaningfully
liberated in the future or whether they
were constrained by the new human
Innovations in some way that made them
actually less free
I suppose what I would add to that I
broadly agree what I would add to that
is that it's certainly possible to
squander
what's best About Us by by constraining
us and impeding us from acting
from being our best selves to put it
crudely
um I would I would contend it's also
possible to contend to to to to squander
that human the the best of the best of
what we can be by an excess of
Liberation that it's possible to go the
other way as well
and that and and that there are
there are better and worse Ways to Live
bluntly
um in accordance with what
with with how how we how we can best
flourish as humans as human organisms in
the context of the the entire Gestalt of
of where we are um in our evolutionary
cultural Etc trajectories so I would
contend that it's not just Liberation
but it's also the beneficial constraints
which enable us to live well that that
bring us to to a good place and where we
can flourish oh I I 100 agree with you
on this
um that Liberty can actually be toxic
this is why I use a nebulous term like
meaningful Liberation right because it
is absolutely possible and in fact we
may be drowning in Trivial Liberation we
are so uh overrun with choice that we
don't even recognize that uh it's a it's
a matter of scale in some sense and I
believe this is actually a theme that is
in your book that in some sense where
you see feminism having gone awry it has
in some sense become obsessed with the
liberty of individual females and has
effectively abandoned responsibility for
anything durable and continuing I mean
right down to its subordination of uh
children to the liberty of their
would-be mothers
yes yes indeed and I mean when I when
I've typed when I titled the book
feminism against progress
um the progress which I'm talking about
is specifically that that vision of the
good which proposes to liberate us from
ever ever more of the constraints that
surround us including where necessary
The Beneficial ones and and which does
so generally speaking via Technologies
which which replace previously phys
embodied limits or social limits with a
technological Freedom you know whether
that's
whether that's the entire trajectory of
industrialization which liberated humans
from all manner of probably pretty
arduous subsistence life in in favor of
you know the great panoply of different
things that people do with themselves
now
but what I've what I've set out to argue
is that when you when you liberate
people when you use a technology to free
people or cultures from constraints what
invariably comes with that what
invariably comes with freedom is also
trade which is to say when you when you
remove something from and I've argued
this really from Carl Palani who's a
political Economist he wrote a I don't
know if you're familiar with the great
transformation which is a 1947 I think
book he wrote about the origins of what
of Market Society you know he set out to
challenge the idea that homoeconomicus
was any was whether it was anything
Universal or Eternal about
homoeconomicus and set out to show how
how this figure was constructed and the
society in which this figure existed had
been constructed principally through the
enclosure of the Commons in the United
Kingdom
um so so I've drawn I've drawn heavily
from Carl Palani and also from Ivan
ilitch's work on pre-modern pre-modern
sex roles where he talks about the the
Industrial Revolution bringing with it a
transition from what he calls vernacular
gender to economic sex in which he sees
women as not more empowered but less
empowered because they're structurally
disadvantaged in a world which claims
that everybody is in is in broadly
interchangeable
um where where our reproductive role and
our our caring are often desired caring
obligations leave us structurally
disadvantaged I mean this is an
extremely reductive summary of an
immensely immensely Rich book which if
if you've if you've not read I I
strongly strongly recommend dipping into
I have an illiter of gender he was very
canceled for it in the 1990s so anyway
this is all this is all to say
that where we've got to with the women's
movement which which emerged rightly and
justly in response to a number of ways
that women genuinely were
um in a in faced with new predicaments
as material circumstances changed
um it has what what it's brought what
it has tracked the well the two things
two things were going on
um on the one hand we've got the the
broader trajectory of Freedom
underwritten by technology
um which which then enables the market
to move into places which had been
previously governed by
by social codes and I've told the
paradigmatic example there is the the
pre-modern guilds which were replaced by
a free market so again this is very this
is very crudely drawn from Poland but
but this is so so this is the and and
what I've what I've set out to argue is
that from the sexual Revolution onwards
um that that movement to liberate us
using technology and to which which we
test we have tacitly accepted invariably
comes with a side order of increased
Commerce has moved from being something
which happens outside in the world with
the enclosure of the commons and then
the enclosure of various you know
natural resources and the and this this
very this extractive approach to the to
the Natural World which has powered our
immense growth in
in in technology and wealth in abundance
in material goods and so on and that
turned inwards with the sexual
Revolution and and and and took took as
its focus and took us its resource to be
enclosed and commodified the human body
and that this was a this was an
absolutely pivotal cultural moment which
which has been hugely underpriced hugely
under under
we don't really take we haven't reckoned
with at all just how radical that
transformation was the point at which we
stopped we stopped strip mining the
world and we started strip mining
ourselves and and I've I've situated
that in the the digital and the sexual
revolutions you know which which formed
twin facets of essentially the same
cultural change which are characterized
as a cyborg era and the part two of the
book I've set out to unpack some of the
ways that the we've emancipated
ourselves using digital and reproductive
Technologies and in in you know
inexorably with that although it's
brought a great dividend of freedom and
you know many changes which have been
positive at least for some people it's
also brought with it a side order of
Commerce and the entry of commodity of
trade into areas where previously it was
very strictly managed or or just
outright forbidden but note it's
noticeable for example in the the
concurrent flourishing of Etc
emancipation and pornography and and the
porn industry the two the two come into
being simultaneously and it's fairly
it's fairly obvious why
um and that that's only accelerated in
the years since and I've set out to to
suggest that there are some undercounted
costs of that emancipation particularly
in in where it leaves the of very long
of
essentially our evolved patterns in mate
choice
and and it's created some increasingly
painful tensions which are having now
now noticeably negative Downstream
consequences for young people who would
otherwise long-ter form families but
find themselves culturally set up to do
pretty much anything but now
yes uh I I can't help but hear a sort of
classic British understatement of the
catastrophe
um you know I without leaping the
conclusions here I wouldn't say that
progress is impossible but I would say
that there is something quite stunning
about the degree to which we do not look
at our obvious freedoms and make the
calculation about what their apparent
cost has been because I think I I share
with you a sense that we have taken
things that are effectively Beyond price
and we have commodified them and while
the upshot of that is not the same for
every person there are people who are
obviously spectacularly liberated and uh
do something meaningful with it but
for most people there appears to be no
awareness of what has been taken from
them
and you know nowhere is this more
obvious to me
than the spectacular decline in the
bargaining position that most women find
themselves in right they have been
commodified and do not seem to recognize
it
um and you know I'm obviously not in a
great place to say that as a man but uh
you know I mean I guess we could make
the same argument uh for you you know
there's an irony in your making this
case because you're obviously a woman
taking advantage of uh an era in which a
woman finds herself in a position to
make this case on a world stage right
that does seem to be uh I would I would
regard that as a kind of progress
um but nonetheless it gives you a
position from which to make the case
that maybe the net effect of all of what
we regard as progress has not been
positive
absolutely and it's it's certainly when
you look at the nuts when you look at
what we've traded off
um particularly in the era in
specifically in the terrain of women's
bodies in exchange for
the the considerable gains in
emancipation I find I find The Ledger
very difficult but I find it very
difficult to say that it's it's been in
that game I mean from from where I'm
sitting I should hold my hands up and
say you're absolutely right that as as
an educated middle class white Western
women it's probably been net positive
for me in fact it's almost indisputably
in that positive for me I mean there's
as you rightly say there's a there are
there are many errors in which I
wouldn't have been given the opportunity
to make this case
um that that that's beyond dispute and
it's and it's clear when you look at the
numbers when you look at how how life
changed for Bourgeois women like me in
in Britain and America alike with the
arrival of the pill it's very clear that
that for women of my of my class and and
education
um it was it wasn't it was a absolutely
radical transformation women women piled
into the universities in huge numbers
women women piled into the workplace in
huge numbers because it was possible you
could plan and it just wasn't possible
to plan before because you either you
either had to have the self-discipline
of a nun or
or just or or just accept that you were
your your your career could be
interrupted by a child at any point
which it just makes it well put it this
way you're not going to be you're not
going to be looking at the same in the
same way of a five or ten year
professional development plan if you can
fall pregnant at any time and have your
have your work
have you have your work trajectory
interrupted
um so so it was it made a huge too
ambitious to ambitious academic the
nerdy women like me it made it made an
immense difference and and that's and
yeah and so we have to weigh that on one
side of The Ledger and say yes there are
a huge number of women who benefited
immensely from being able to control our
fertility in this way
um but it but inexorably with with
freedom comes trade and the point and
the point where sexuality women's sexual
women's bodies in particular stopped
being managed via social norms and
social codes because I mean that was
that the the sexual trouble standards is
is real and it was and it emerged for a
reason I mean for very practical firm
but it historically it's been pretty
brutal and you know the shaming of women
who who fall foul of sexual Norms has
historically been pretty brutal but it
was done for a very pragmatic reason you
know if you if absent reliable
contraception because that everybody
around you really does have skin in the
game in terms of what you do what you do
with your body and who you who you have
sex with this is this this is obvious
and so you you can complain all you like
about how it's patriarchal and unfair
but but from from the point of view of
everybody else in your village who's
otherwise going to have to figure out
what to do with the baby you know you
can you can sort of see why people got
there and how these how these social
norms emerged and then at a stroke Along
Comes this technology that says actually
you just don't need any of that anymore
you know so all of a sudden it became
thinkable for the first time ever that
that women's sexual women's bodies you
know nobody really nobody did have any
any say or any stake in in who I chose
to have sex with it became thinkable for
the first time ever and an entire
infrastructure of social codes and
courtship rights and you know the the
immense immensely complicated business
of older usually some personally told
emotions like I am now doing doing their
best to stop horny young people from
from getting to getting over excited at
least until they were married all just
disappeared and it became possible to
think of my body just belongs to me and
before that just wasn't a meaningful
statement to make because it just
because in the case of women and it
wasn't really true
um and then but the dancer and so so
this is great if you're like me in
Europe you're a academically ambitious
and you want to do
X Y and Z with your life
um if you're if you're poor and
uneducated and all of a sudden your body
sudden your body belongs to you
um you still fall within the the larger
the larger fields of the larger moral
field that's been transformed but you
you maybe you maybe don't necessarily
have the same set of things that you
might want to do with yourself and with
your with your with your suddenly
Newfound freedom however you still have
the same freedom to do what you like
with your own body now let's say let's
say you're very impoverished let's say
you're you don't have very many
prospects let's say you're under you're
you're under great financial pressure
you have this thing that belongs to you
and and one and something that belongs
to you you can dispose of as you see fit
so all of a sudden along with along with
the huge opportunities for capable
ambitious women at the top of the social
hierarchy it also often it also okay
what what came with that was the
libertarian defense of the sex industry
um which in practice ended up being a
Libertarian defense so the sexual
exploitation of impoverished women
in a way which had been yes yes has gone
on since time immemorial but was what
could suddenly be justified with using
the same rubric as was used to
emancipate women to go after to to get
phds and and join the medical profession
or whatever
so yeah so along with freedom comes
trade and what it is that gets traded
isn't necessarily is isn't necessarily
just going to be a women's immense
immense professional potential in the
market it may it turned out in practice
to sometimes also just be women's bodies
uh I I agree with almost everything you
just said starting with the fact that
people
appear to have no idea
what the logic of sexuality was even
about right I'm frequently struck by the
fact that people seem
surprised to discover that
sex is itself a fundamentally
reproductive thing which in humans has
been elaborated so that it does some
other jobs but if you don't understand
the uh the rudiments of sex as
reproductive then you don't understand
why all of the asymmetries arose around
it and it is those asymmetries
to which modern folks are in general in
Rebellion but it is very different to be
in Rebellion against them if you know
what they're for and you you know it's a
chesterton's fence problem right those
things existed for a reason
I very much agree with your point that
birth control
uh is the first step of transhumanism
I did not realize that until you said it
but it immediately struck a chord that
transhumanism begins with the ability to
control uh when and how frequently you
reproduce and that that is in my opinion
uh a
powerfully good thing to have control
over but what did not come with it was
any sense of how many things were
Downstream from it so there was no
ability to generate a new kind of wisdom
about okay given that a woman is now
free to choose when to reproduce what
else that you know was once part of a
coherent way of organizing a society is
now suddenly going to be cut adrift and
where we find ourselves now
is in a kind of
painful counterproductive chaos in which
people have gained sexual Liberation but
they do not appear to have gained sexual
satisfaction out of it they just have a
kind of technical contrary in fact right
they appear to be uh addicted and
dissatisfied
on mass which suggests that there's
something and you know again I would
point to the question of
is it inherently a mistake to engage in
technological Family Planning I don't
really believe so but I do think that
the you know what we did Downstream of
that change has been
I won't say an unmitigated disaster but
it's been a mitigated disaster there
have been many positive things but wow
have the consequences for human
flourishing uh been mixed
I think that's absolutely right now I've
really I really want to emphasize again
that this is not about me just saying we
we have to turn the clock back and we
have to put all these Technologies back
in their box because either a that's not
possible and B everything the the social
mores that we had before are now so so
completely gone and have evaporated with
really the generation before my mother's
generation and perhaps perhaps where
another's generation was the last to to
hold really to pre-sexual Revolution
Morris in any in any numbers and we're
along we're a long way a long way along
from that now and I then things have
changed so radically even since I was
since I was young and at the sharp end
of the quote-unquote sexual Marketplace
which is an idea which I dispute you
know in its as a frame for what
sexuality is and how it functions and
how it ought to function I think the the
fact that the fact that it's become
normalized to to talk to to refer to
the the process of make choice and make
formation as a sexual Marketplace
I mean we could spend another hour
unpacking what that term means and why
it's such a category error when it comes
to when it comes to what sexuality is
for and and how we should be thinking
about it
um but but I think it it's it speaks it
speaks volumes about about how what is
what exactly we're getting wrong and how
it is that we're thinking mistakenly
about it to think of it as a Marketplace
to think of it as something which is
individualistic and transactional and in
which everybody must must of necessity
with pursuing their own interest that's
just a fundamentally mistaken way to
think about what sexuality is and what
it's for and how it can be how it can be
use how it can be a healthy and
beneficial part of who we are as humans
well I would I would push back very
slightly I think I agree with the
sentiment but I would argue that this is
a case where
sex breaks down into if you disrupt the
higher version of it is a marketplace
right that it's the it's a lower state
of existence and it's very hard to make
the case especially to people who are
addicted to some product produced in
that Marketplace that they have given up
something the name of which they don't
even know
right there is something yes this is
exactly it it's sex shouldn't be a
Marketplace but it is yes this is where
we are now very well said yeah so there
shouldn't be a Marketplace but it is
um and it is interesting I I don't know
uh my social group is of course
idiosyncratic but
it is interesting how frequently I am
now running into uh the pattern of women
let's say in their mid-30s and onward
waking up to their own philosophical
error discovering that things that they
were convinced of they now believe we're
not in their interest and making a
radical change in their uh their
trajectory which I think is very
positive but it's also a bit tragic that
it comes late in other words that
something about the messaging that
Society is delivering to these women
when they're very young is irresistible
and you know how much better off well I
will make two arguments one it would be
great if you had that wisdom early on so
that you could avoid the pitfalls
earlier in your life because it's not
that those costs go away entirely when
you wake up right some of those costs
are just simply permanent
um
but that it is also the case that
we in order to understand why this
sexual Marketplace that things have
broken down into is so pervasive
one need only look at the plight of an
individual woman especially who attempts
to opt out
right you know in a world where people
have become very transactional about sex
and effectively have started swapping in
quantity for quality not realizing that
they've given something up a woman who
decides not to make that error uh
has very little access to anyone's
attention and I believe it is that
tragedy that makes it impossible for or
not impossible but very unlikely for the
culture to substantially correct its
course
right it just it's a it's a vicious
cycle
well I'm cautiously optimistic on that
front but I think if I think it will
take a it will take a wholesale Mutiny
by by the next generation of hot girls
yeah a huge amount of a huge amount of
culture it's Downstream of what the hot
girls want I 100 agree with you that is
exactly right um and the problem for
that opportunity
is that those hot girls
now have
um
access they can the hottest girls can
monetize that hotness in a way that is
disproportionate and therefore they are
disincentivized
to do so because effectively they may
have given up something in terms of uh
human satisfaction and well-being but
they've gained a tremendous amount of
earning capacity which is misleading to
women who don't have those opportunities
it's like NBA stars leading people to
think that you know if they play the
game really well that they're going to
end up rich when the the answer is no
that's only true for people in the very
tale of a distribution it's not true in
general
the worst case scenario is is as you
describe it they the hot girls go on
setting a terrible example for everybody
else
um the more optimistic scenario
um sees enough of a backlash
um that that also has a trickle-down
effect and I I see to be honest I see
evidence of both and I don't know which
way it's going to go yet but I'm I'm of
course because I because I I choose to
have hope for for humans generally I
prefer to think that enough enough women
are going to wake up and and decide that
this is this is just not this is not
working well I I guess I would put my
help I would put my hope somewhere
slightly different I put my hope in
people like you and Louise Perry and
British Bridget fettesee and my wife
Heather highing who are presenting a
very powerful case that is not I mean
even in
your
um framework which does argue for a
rejection of modernity
uh and I think no uncertain terms
even in your case you are
you are not really laying out the case
for a return to somewhere in the past
you are laying out the case that many of
the things we have abandoned from the
past we did so at our apparel
and that we should think about how they
might be recovered which I think is the
right is the right way to look at the
puzzle
I think that's right I found a wonderful
quotation from the Colombian aphorus
Nicolas Gomez Davila who says the true
reactionary is not a Seeker after
abolished posts but a hunter of sacred
shades on the Eternal Hills uh those are
words to write by for me we can't go
back
this is one of uh Heather and my
principles we cannot go back there is in
fact nowhere to go back to
um exactly there's and there's nothing
left to concern
you know the and one of the points that
I made in feminism against progress is
is exactly this that people people love
to people love to daydream about what
they call traditional gender roles and I
and I say well the the trouble yeah what
people generally referring to there is
something from in the arc from about
1850 to 1950 where where sex roles were
very those are the male Breadwinner and
notionally a female private domestic
Bourgeois housewife and this is this is
a a pattern which looms very large in
both the right and the left
um imaginary for different reasons
although they disagree about what it
means but that's what people mean when
they talk about traditional gender roles
and my my critique of that is not that
it's traditional but it's not
traditional enough and I I think we
should go back to something I think if
we want to if we want a template to
model what we could do more healthily
from where we are now rather than where
we were between 1850 and 1950 we might
look considerably further back at the at
about productive households and and
consider whether there are there's any
any of the affordances of the 21st
century might might bring us closer to
that kind of a model and and offer offer
new new ways of working together
in such as such as to create more space
for family and different ways of working
and yeah more creative to the more
Creative Solutions to the problem of who
does what and where and when and more
flexible solutions to that then a
fantasized return to a past where whose
material conditions are just dead and
gone now anyway
yes uh I believe what has happened
is we have made a classic error of
progressives faced with a complex
problem and I don't mean complicated I
mean complex in the technical sense
which is
one cannot
anticipate the consequences of a change
in a truly complex adaptive environment
and instead of Behaving with caution
when we upend something major like for
example we introduce technological birth
control
that is sufficient for Meaningful Family
Planning
we do not
then carefully monitor the impact on
things that we have separately decided
are valuable so that we can discover if
we've made an error if there's a
refinement that is necessary right if
there's some way to to balance the costs
and benefits instead what we have done
is we've entered an era of what Heather
and I call hyper novelty where the rate
of change is so fast that not only are
you not
trained for the world in which you
become an adult because that world
literally didn't exist when you were
young
but the rate of change is so high that
it is not even in principle within the
uh capacity of selection to keep up
right you don't run a scientific
experiment by changing a hundred things
at once and then trying to figure out
which thing affected what you change one
thing at a time and in our culture it's
not even a hundred things at once it's
everything is being altered all the time
around us which means these utterly
profound changes their impacts can't be
tracked because they're buried in
statistical noise of all sorts of other
changes that had impacts many of which
will be trivial but can't be can't be
isolated
yeah in my gloomier moments Brett I look
at the collapsing birth rate across the
across the developed and increasingly
also the the developing world and I
think well we you could if if you were
feeling pessimistic you could just see
this as a form of evolutionary feedback
it just says you know this is this is
just not a way of living which is
conducive to its perpetuating itself
yeah and something is going to have to
shift
or or it just isn't going to well but
here's here's the the ultimate problem
here on the one hand I'm I'm tempted to
draw that same connection and I resist
doing it because I believe that if that
is what's going on it's really
uh you know that almost sounds like a
kind of evolutionary wisdom which I'm
convinced it isn't I'm convinced it's
more like
A system that is incoherent does not
send the right messages to the body that
cause it to be in a reproductive uh a
physio physiologically reproductive mode
um and so it would be almost
happenstance that our chaos is
triggering that mechanism rather than
than wisdom
um but what is ordinarily true in human
evolution
is that
at any one moment some
lineage May experiment with something
radically different and that radically
thing May provide a benefit more often
than not it will be
negative
and that lineage can either reverse
course when it realizes that what it's
doing has not been a net benefit or it
can go extinct and be replaced by others
that didn't take that path and
unfortunately
our modern hype our our hyper novel
world that we moderns live in
has linked us all together so
instead of the culture having a
an outburst of feminism to which many
people opted out it sort of took over
the whole culture which did not leave
a
uh a population to which to compare
right and that is increasingly a global
problem where Because the Internet takes
every idea and spreads it almost
everywhere instantaneously we are sort
of all dragged into the same experiment
over and over again and there's no
capability to say well here's what you
imagined was going to happen Downstream
of that change and here's what actually
happened and maybe it wasn't as good an
idea as you thought
yeah certainly
liberating the world's information has
had some unexpected side effects I
definitely agree with that
um
I I don't know I I look at I look at the
way the internet is evolving and which
is also happening just incredibly
mind-bogglingly first and you know there
are all sorts of Dumas scenarios
floating around at the moment with
artificial intelligence and so on but I
I think it's not impossible that people
will regain a measure of
well the the internet will will become
semi-delibately and much more siled over
time and that because people realize
that just everybody being networked in
that way just just isn't good in fact I
would argue that it's probably already
happening I mean the most most there was
a point I think probably from the late
noughties up to about Trump's election
year give or take maybe a bit beyond
that where everybody really did have all
of their conversations in public on the
internet and I just don't think that's
the case anymore
um there are there are too many too many
whole whole hallway monitors and there
are too many ways that you can you can
face negative consequences the things
that you say to the wrong audience on
the internet
and most most serious conversations now
happen in Gate kept communities and I
think that that will just go on
happening and some subcultures will will
be will find ways of diverging again
yeah in my observation that's already
taking place to an extent so so again
I'm not without hope that people the
cultures people and cultures will adapt
beyond that sort of pathological state
of openness and I sincerely hope that we
do because if we if not then we Face the
problem that you've described
yes although you know look I uh I I
desperately want to sign on to the hope
that you keep returning to and you know
I have my own reasons for help I guess
but what I'm concerned about is that
that's siloing while you could imagine a
productive version of it and in fact uh
what I would advocate for any young
person who hears a conversation like
this one and thinks oh well what am I to
do my suggestion would be
to find a community of people to opt out
of the modern sensibilities together
right one would need to figure out what
what the new rules of sex and sexuality
ought to be in a community that intends
to function that does value family that
also values uh meaningful Liberation not
just trivial liberation
and you know opt out together is really
what I would hope to see which is
another way of describing Siloam even my
concern is you do a pretty good job of
articulating
the
um
the misleading of young people that is
taking place as you know the example you
used was a Libertarian approach to
um to the sex uh sex industry
um it's genuinely shocking to me that
there are there are now courses for
freshers that you know fresh for
freshman students at University on
starting and only funds or engaging even
in real life sex work I find that just
mind-bogglingly
right
beyond beyond raw I do I do too
um and I also find the connection to
libertarianism both wrong-headed and
deeply unfortunate because what it does
is it turns that into a
pseudo-sophistication
and the problem I'm sure you have found
the same is when you try to make the
counter argument it is understood to be
born of prudishness
right now in my case I don't feel that
that is an accurate
uh evaluation at all in fact I would
argue that the problem and I I know you
you feel similarly the problem is that
we are not treating sex as extremely
special that it is a an extremely
special thing and we have
trivialized it and it is the
trivialization of sex that results in US
commodifying it so it isn't prudishness
it's actually uh you know
if sex positivity wasn't already a
polluted term you might describe this
view that sex is very special as sex
positivity
um but
this is a long way of saying I think
unfortunately
young people
who have not lived long enough to
develop wisdom
are
easily tricked and that their whether it
is you know the industry doing the
tricking or wealthy men on the take or
whatever it is or on the make I should
say whatever it is there's an awful lot
of bandwidth being
spent tricking young people into a false
sophistication around sex and sexuality
that then unfortunately requires
recovery later rather than as you are
hoping that there's a silo where people
who wish to opt out of that nonsense can
go from the beginning
yeah I think what's what's particularly
fascinating about what you call the sort
of false sense of sophistication about
sex and sexuality is that it's arrived
as far as as far as I can make out from
the data in tandem with an absolute drop
in people having sex in real life which
is a it's a I'm on the face of it it's a
really interesting Paradox because on
the one hand you've got all these people
who are who are who are identifying as
demisexual or bisexual or Ace Arrow or
you know whatever whatever they've come
up with this week
um you're coming up with increasingly
Baroque and fine-grained terms to Define
their own sexualities but on the other
hand they've probably never had sex with
anybody
and the age the age of loss of virginity
is going up some you know plenty of kids
just
you know the the kids are not doing it
they're not getting it on and it's it's
difficult to avoid the conclusion that
what they're actually describing when
they when they identify as this or that
factuality is just is there acquired
porn preferences
because it's very difficult to see where
else they might have been they might
have been getting this information from
such as to be able to come up with these
hyper-specific
um ideas of who who and who and what
they who and what they are and who what
their orientation is I mean and as you
as you write they say this is It's a
deeply troubling foundation for
in any sort of realistic Prospect of
forming a long-term relationship if in
fact you're you're setting out to create
a social and a cultural or even a
political identity from sexual
preferences which which haven't emerged
you know in out of nothing you know they
haven't emerged from as it were from a
blank slate they've been inculcated you
know more often than not via porn
consumption or or via the sort of
memetic influence of their peers and you
think that this stuff is all sloshing
around and it's and and it's increasing
or and it's ever less grounded in any
actual actual physical desires it's not
grounded in Eros it's not grounded in
any sort of an eye of our encounter with
with an actual physical Desiring other
that this is all happening purely in the
realm of idea and you think well how do
you how do you even get from doing that
at the age of 15 to forming a long-term
relationship that someone specified
point in the future how do you how do
you make that transition I mean sure you
know when I was when I had crushes as a
teenager and it was all extremely
abstract but the but but the certain
that there wasn't this additional layer
of social and political meaning making
that was able to occur around that and
then persist into adult life and and
yeah I mean I've been I've I've been
honestly amusebread to find myself being
the more optimistic side of our
conversation because I'm used I'm
usually the Doomer and I leave people
feeling deeply miserable so I'm kind of
enjoying being Napoleonic on this
occasion but yeah on the on this side
I'm as troubled as you I'm as I'm deeply
worried about
about what it what it is that we're
doing what what it is that we're doing
to to the kids who grew up on the
internet and to the kids who grow up in
in the pervasively pornified universe I
mean you hear horror stories about 15
year old girls who are who are so badly
injured after after seeking to imitate
acts that they'd seen in in porn footage
that they that they'll they'll they'll
they'll need a colostomy bag for life I
mean yeah truly horrific injuries are
coming Downstream of this because people
just don't
don't make the connection people it's
that they're trying to enact something
which is never meant to be enacted and
they're trying to enact something which
is which is only ever meant to be an
idea and and somewhere in the middle of
all of this as you say you know what
what it was a what it was what it's for
what we evolved it for because has
become completely lost and I think and
the the a challenge which which I
suspect is pretty near the root of this
is that the moment the moment you push
back and you say well can we talk about
can we talk about what is actually for
which is to say you know heterosexual
reproduction you know desire is there
fundamentally to make more humans then
people
said the pushback that you'll get from
the progressive side on that
um is it is you'll be called
heterosexist you'll be called
patriarchal you'll be called you'll be
called any number of other any number of
other boo words all of which really boil
down to a horror at being reminded of
our embodied reality and the immutable
nature of our embodied reality and
to me to be violently did an unhinged
aversion to being reminded that we can't
in fact Escape our embodied nature
well there are a number of themes there
I want to be sure to pick up on
um one of them you you point to this
world in which people are spending a lot
of time identifying with some newly
invented
uh category of sexual orientation
and unfortunately I think the
explanation for this
is pretty pretty clear
that this is in effect what happened
with
physical activity
right where at one time children would
have played a sport and they would have
been very passionate about it
and what has happened is that has been
transmuted into an act of consumerism
where what you do is you support a team
or you're very Avid about a particular
sport that you watch on your television
and so you are you know instead of
playing baseball you're consuming
baseball and instead of actually
pursuing sex which is of course uh in a
natural circumstance
a very difficult puzzle to solve because
the consequences
before birth control for women having
sex with somebody were so spectacularly
high that women in general would not
consider having sex with anybody who did
not show very strong evidence of a
willingness to commit
um so that was the sort of fundamental
underlying logic of sex it was very very
scarce and one had to achieve
substantial things in order to become
worthy of it and that you know kind of
logic to the system but once you remove
that then it becomes
you know you almost have people
um aligning with some
specialized version of sex in the same
way that they you know root for
Manchester United or whatever it is
um it's it's a radical transition in
one's relationship to to sexuality
the other the other thing I wanted to
introduce here and this is again a place
where I just have a very hard time
conveying to people what I'm talking
about but I think the problem in some
sense comes down to the idea that sex is
a recreational activity
and if you say oh it's not recognition
then people assume that what you're
saying is it's utilitarian yeah that
it's utilitarian when in fact it is
supposed to be
um
extremely
private
and
unthinkably powerful
and that combination of things is part
of the logic that we've lost and so
we've substituted in this very low
quality oh sex is something you can do
with anybody right
um and yeah I've made a very similar
case actually in the last chapter of the
book where I've I've I've made the case
for rewilding as I called it rewilding
sex and which is it's really it's the
pro sex case against birth control on
the basis that you know in much the same
way as to rewild an area of to rewild an
ecosystem sometimes you have to
reintroduce the apex predator because
otherwise the ecosystem just doesn't
work you know my argument is that we we
won't be able to we won't be able to
move Sex out of this this empty sterile
recreational terrain and back into its
proper seriousness and take it seriously
and with the pleasures that come with
that unless we're willing to reintroduce
the danger and although I can't prove it
although I can't prove it um it is my
hunch that a great deal of the so on
so-called BDSM culture would disappear
overnight if we if we allowed the true
seriousness and the true danger of of
what sex is actually for back into the
picture again you know all of these
young women who are who are being choked
or slapped or otherwise otherwise
physically abused and a lot of them
genuinely want it this is a
controversial thing to say
um and this and my my great friend
Louise Perry will we argue back and
forth about BDSM and it's it's clear
enough to me from from women I speak to
that a great many of them they you know
they ask and I hear I hear from this
from young men as well that girls girls
who they're with they're asking to be
choked or slapped or whatever and and
it's and and honestly Brett I think it's
because they just want to feel something
um that's what's going on and if if if
you take I mean you know being being
slightly more flippant about it you know
contraceptive sex is like vegan bacon
you know it kind it's kind of the same
but is it any wonder that people are
adding a lot of hot sauce because the
flavor just isn't quite there
um yeah and I think if you add the
danger back in then a lot of the a lot
of the violence the degradation and the
the extreme and the sexual tribalism
that you've been characterizing would
would disappear well I think there are
two ways that we could view your
argument one of them I think is almost
certainly true which is if you did
reintroduce the high stakes nature
that you would see a clarification of
people's uh sexual selves I won't say
instantly because many people you know
will never get over being Downstream of
all the porn they've watched but quickly
you would see that transition the
question is is that the only way and I
this is where I don't know if you and I
differ but I would argue it is not the
only way
um that basically the if one were to opt
out as a couple or as a community
and opt into rules that again restored
the specialness and basically that's
I guess a code word here for the
scarcity of sex in other words that it
is the result of
um really impressing somebody I suppose
that that would do it without
necessarily having to
uh eliminate birth control from the
scenario because as you said earlier in
the conversation whether or not it would
be a good idea to eliminate birth
control I do not think it would but
whether or not it would it won't happen
right we've already uh all right no I
completely agree that but however
um it's it's perfectly within the power
of any young woman who I mean there are
there are great many young women all
over tiktok and Instagram and wherever
else
um talking about having how they were
put on birth control at the age of 14
and then they they came off it in their
early 20s and had a complete personality
transplant and are now outraged of what
happened to them or what was done to
them you know when they were they were
they were given this this extremely
psychoactive substance for a number of
years which completely de-risks de-risks
sex and left them left them without any
robust reason to say no to any number of
Acts which you know some some of them
some of them now greatly regret
um and and have now come off it and
discovered that there's a whole a whole
raft of psychological symptoms which
they thought was just something that
they had to live with was in fact this
medication which they were taking in
order to in in order to make them
consequence free participants in the
quote-unquote sexual Marketplace and
there are a lot of young women who are
extremely angry about that and now and
you know natural natural Family Planning
is a subculture all of its own among
women a great a great deal younger than
me and certain and not even just
religious conservatives not by a long
talk and and again I keep coming back to
the optimism it must just must just be
something about you but you you really
bring it out to me but one of the really
positive stories potentially well one of
one of the more positive uses of tech
that I've I've heard of recently is a
huge number of advances in in Tech which
supports
um are more embodied and a more realist
approach to to Family Planning so there
are there are technological Innovative
there are acts there are there are there
are other technology which which have
been developed which support
um being able to work with your natural
cycles as a woman and to be able to
manage your fertility in that way
without having to without having to take
this to take a pill which messes up your
endocrine system and makes you fat and
sexless and mad
um just in in order to in order to take
the complexity out of it and I think
that you know Innovations like that
which work with our organismic nature
rather than against it I see us for you
being potentially hugely positive but
they all take more effort and at the end
of the day you know if if a change if
change is going to come on this it will
begin with women because the sexual
Revolution began with women it began
with women saying yes to this Paradigm
and it will end with women saying we've
had enough of this
yeah I agree with you um you know and
again I will probably be accused of
sexism for agreeing with you on this
point but it does come down to women for
a number of different reasons one in a
commodified culture where commitment is
not expected the burden
of raising Offspring Falls to women for
reasons that are not fair but are deeply
biological and have nothing to do with
humans oppressing each other just has to
do with an asymmetry in our reproductive
modes
um but yes women will have to
to correct our course if anybody is
going to
and actually it
um
there's a an exercise that I want to
just put on the table here because it's
something that I feel
in any discussion of evolution sex and
sexuality it is just simply a necessary
piece of the puzzle
um so without delaying any further let
me just put it this way
whether you are male or female
morphologically comes down to
um effectively a single switch that
lives on the Y chromosome in humans
if that switch is present you become
male if the switch is absent because you
have two X chromosomes instead of a y
you become female but interestingly if
you have a y chromosome and that switch
is defective you also become female
that's the default mode
and what that means
is that it is perfectly conceivable for
any human being watching or listening to
this podcast
that you could have an identical twin
that is somebody who shares your entire
genome but is of the opposite sex based
on whether that switch is added in or
subtracted
that means it's not your genome being
male which takes a particular approach
to sex it is your genome being willing
to play either role
and being triggered into one set of
strategies or another based on whether
or not that switch uh triggers a
developmental change
and I find this very powerful because it
puts the LIE
to the idea that what happened to women
was that man oppressed them
and in fact
it is certainly true that we do not
choose our sex and that historically
speaking whatever sex we were born into
came with obligations and burdens that
were special that would have been absent
had we been born the other way right if
you were a woman then reproduction is
likely uh going to be
um and especially burdensome operation
for you if you're male you run the risk
of
Going To War uh you know these are
asymmetries it's not clearly better to
be one than the other
but in any case the idea that every time
a zygote is created there is a lottery
that dictates whether it's going to live
its life as a male or a female and that
most of the genome knows nothing about
how that Lottery is going to work out
until it's already happened and then you
play your role just the same way if
you're genetically endowed with genes
that make you tall you play that role if
you have genes that don't make you tall
then that's the life you live it's just
luck of the draw but it isn't the story
of you know
boy genomes oppressing girl genomes and
it never has been that it's not to say
that men have not impressed women but
that's it's not a simple story of of a
genetic of an evolutionary
um conflict between the sexes
yeah I don't really believe in
patriarchy I mean I think there are
there are phenomena that we can describe
as patriarchal and there are clearly
patriarchal cultures
um but I
I think we we need to assess those
cultures in their own context and in
their own under their own material
conditions
um you know and and when when you do
that it's often fairly clear how why it
is that they came to be the way they are
um and and under it's it's pretty clear
to me that this the culture that we live
in now is not patriarchal and if any if
anything it's the opposite of
patriarchal in the sense that most of
the most of the obligations and the
expectations and the strictures that
were placed on that are placed on men
within a patriarchal culture are not are
not heavily present now
um for a whole host of quite complicated
reasons and yet what I find fascinating
is that that hasn't stopped people
talking about patriarchy and it hasn't
stopped it hasn't stopped them women
wanting to smash the patriarchy and I
puzzled over this for a long time
thinking well there isn't there isn't
really one left to smash in any sort of
you know I mean it is it's not as though
you know coventure is not a thing
anymore women get to vote you know most
in most in most ordinary contexts you
know there really is very little
difference between the Sexes so what
what actually are women talking about
here and and it came it came to me at
last I was reading a history of women
and Medicine there was I mean in some
parts it was quite long research but the
thing I found frustrating about it was
that every time every time something
came along that the author didn't like
um she would blame it on patriarchy so
for example let me see the the fact that
male doctors didn't want to get involved
in childbirth was patriarchal but then
when male doctors wanted to get involved
in childbirth that was them pushing out
the female midwives and that was also a
patriarch and there were a whole lot of
instances and I was I was I was reading
this and I was thinking you can't really
have it both ways you know these these
things can't all be patriarchal you know
anesthetizing women who are giving birth
isn't patriarchal if not anesthetizing
woman who are giving birth is also a
patriarchal that doesn't make sense so
which is it and I came to the conclusion
that in fact what she what she meant in
aggregate the inference over the course
of the book was that what she meant by
patriarchy was imageable sex differences
that really and and ever since then
every time I come across a modern day
usage of patriarchy I try I experiment
to see if see if I can substitute it out
and have it make more sense if I replace
it with immutable sex differences that I
don't like
and I have yet to find a contemporary
instance of the word patriarchy which
can't be can't be better replaced and
more coherently replaced with immutable
sex differences I don't like
no I think and you know I mean there are
plenty of there are plenty of situations
where I don't like the immutable
physiological morphological female form
that I have there are times it's
annoying and frustrating but it's not
patriarchy
yes I think you have this one exactly
right and in fact I have made this exact
point that patriarchal is real
patriarchy is a fiction
um and you're you're also correct about
the immutable characteristics right yes
it is oppressive that uh women are
disproportionately called upon to feed
infants
but it wasn't men who did that right uh
if it was anything about maleness it
happened so many hundreds of millions of
years ago that had nothing to do with a
creature that had any culture at all
right it was just simply an imbalance
um that cause you know we call it uh
anisogamy that basically once you have a
set of gametes that is
disproportionately invested in the
survival of Offspring it causes the
other set of gametes to cheap out and
that has consequences that continue to
Echo into our current form but you know
it wasn't
men who had anything to do with it there
were no men it was some biological truth
in the universe that is so deep we even
see that asymmetry in plants which
inherited it from someplace different so
anyway yes
um I wish I wish people would not leap
to the conclusion
that everything was so human-centric
that
um to the extent that they feel burdened
by something that has something to do
with sex or gender that it must be the
other sex or gender doing it that's just
not not the case so anyway I I agree
with your formulation completely
um yeah
foreign
go on yeah I remember that I just what
came to mind for me there was a moment
shortly after my daughter was born yeah
as I'm sure you know newborns go through
phases of cluster feeding because they
want to they want to bring up your milk
supply so they can grow which basically
means that you're stuck there under a
feeding newborn sometimes for hours at a
time it hurts
um it's it's it's not it's not
especially fun I mean it's not the
moment of radiant radiant motherhood
which is idealized in the million to one
images it's it's it's a
um and I remember I remember sitting
there under crying literally crying
under a cluster feeding infant and my
husband bringing me a glass of wine and
a cheese sandwich because that was
um and just being you know Brave Mary
and you know please carry on you know I
wish I could help but I can't and and
just yeah that that was what came to
mind it wasn't his fault that he
couldn't help you know this is this is
just this is just how uh this is just
how humans are built and this is this is
just what being after a baby is that's
just one part and parcel of it if you
happen to be this sex rather than that
sex and I guess I could have I could
have felt angry with him if I'd been
feeling extremely postpartum and
unreasonable but yeah it didn't yeah I
wasn't being oppressed in that way
except just buying my own physiology and
that's certainly not the fault of the
patriarchy that's just the way that's
just the shape humans are
yep I remember a moment late in one of
Heather's pregnancies
uh where she looked at me she had anger
in her eyes but it was clear that it
wasn't at me and she said this is a
goddamn stupid way to reproduce
[Laughter]
very new humans yep absolutely I happen
to know that she had marsupials on her
mind at the moment thinking that they
had a smarter way of doing it but
um they had it all figured out well I
don't know about all figured out but
certainly better figured out
um
so uh I guess
there were a couple last points I've
I've forgotten where they fit in the uh
in the discussion here but there were a
couple things that came up in things
that you said that I wanted to make sure
were included before we before we wrap
up here
um
one of them is about the behavior that
you were describing
uh women being beaten up during sex and
your difficult truth that in fact in
some cases they are asking for this
and I wanted to point out a
yes okay I suppose maybe they're asking
for this to happen
um but in part they're asking for it to
happen because it is expected that they
will ask right now I watch no porn so I
don't really know I'm going on reports
by other people
um but porn has normalized sexual
violence to such a degree
that I think young people who naturally
look to
sexual examples around them are finding
porn and unfortunately taking it in as
if it were informative about what sex is
supposed to look like
and I would also just add to that that
this is this is a great place to see the
issue of something that is not supposed
to be transactional right it's not to
say that there's no aspect of
transactional behavior in normal sex but
it has been made utterly transactional
and it has been commodified by an
industry that feeds sexual appetites
with no
uh no negative consequence for that
industry if people are made unhealthy
unhappy unsatisfied
um as a as a result of consuming this
particular product but in any case what
I wanted to point out is
the thing about porn is you've got a
bunch of vendors that have basically
become parasites on human sexuality that
they are selling human sex acts and it
is very hard to distinguish your
particular brand from anybody else's in
that market because you're all selling
the same thing and what that does is it
means that in order in the competition
for attention uh and therefore dollars
in pornography
you have a natural tendency towards
extreme sexual behavior
right yes as I understand it
um Regular consumers will swiftly become
desensitized as well so you have to go
looking for more extreme content simply
to feel anything at all after a certain
point I mean Louise writes very
compellingly about this she calls it
cultural death grip
yes after the the young men who talk
about death grip syndrome which is to
say they they're unable to unable to
experience an orgasm except through
manipulating themselves in extreme and
painful ways and they're just not able
not able to to have a normal an orgasm
their normal intercourse tall anymore
because they've just they've just
they walked there what their nerve
endings and their their mental Pathways
to to the extent that it's just not
possible anymore yes and unfortunately
what they don't understand you know I
think it's a little bit no it's a lot
like an addictive product like
cigarettes where the person who smokes a
cigarette
yeah they think it may you know will
give them a high does not understand
that they are
changing what normal feels like and so
this is a developmental process that is
you know I won't say it's not reversible
at all I don't know I'm not an expert
but it's not easily reversed and what
that means you know it
again I there are things about the
evolutionary story of what human
sexuality is that are profound and I
think also just not well understood by
most humans
one is that
sex in humans doesn't look like other
creatures right sex in humans serves the
same role it serves in other creatures
but we have been granted
this incredible gift this is a a bonding
exercise
and that is why it continues after the
cessation of reproductive capacity after
menopause that's why it happens in
humans when females are not fertile not
at a fertile point in their cycle this
is something that selection has altered
in humans for something very important
which is bonding with somebody whom
you're going to team up with in the
raising of a family
and so then the upshot of these two
arguments put together
is if you turn your sexuality over to
Outsiders who have no interest in your
long-term well-being if you Outsource
your sexual fantasizing to pornographers
and they Embrace an extreme and violent
view of sex because that's the only way
for them to sell what they're selling
and compete with their competitors then
at the point that you take that very
powerful gift that you have and you
attempt to use it to form a partnership
with somebody a lifelong partnership
then you know what do you do with all
the Despicable stuff that got loaded
into your your sexual mindset
right that stuff now absolutely
Interfaith is what the person who you
should be trying to keep it away from
um
absolutely
once once it's in there it's very hard
to get rid of it again yeah yeah exactly
all right well this has been a great
conversation uh I uh I don't know if I
should feel uh triumphant or defeated in
having been the darker party in this
conversation but whichever way it is I
accept it
um is there anything any final uh words
of wisdom you you'd like to impart
I always think of them later
um so I think I'll I'll just leave it
here and say thank you so much for
testing me on what I mean by progress I
mean I've thank you for taking this in
in different directions and encouraging
me to think more about the
thank you
about the evolutionary aspect of which
is something I've already drawn into my
work but it's been a great pleasure to
delve into that with somebody as
knowledgeable on the subject as you just
thank you I've greatly enjoyed this
conversation I appreciate it yeah I've
enjoyed it as well and I uh sincerely
appreciate the seriousness with which
you have approached the subject and I
will say if I can step out of my my role
of Darkness here I do find something
very hopeful in uh you're laying out the
case this way uh Louise Perry
um Heather rigid fantasy
uh and and many others I think we are
beginning to see a serious conversation
especially amongst very serious women
who have something uh deeply wise to
convey so in any case thank you for
doing that and and I really appreciate
you joining me here on Dark Horse
um your book is out what date
Wednesday the 25th of April the
publisher in the United States is
regular ebooks it's available for
pre-order now uh yeah it drops on the
25th of April and it is communism
against progress feminism against
progress excellent and I know you're not
big on social media but is there
someplace people can find you online I
guess unheard would be one place I tweet
at moving circles that's my Twitter
handle I have a sub stack at reactionary
feminist reactionary
feminist.substack.com you can find most
of my work at unheard where I'm a weekly
columnist wonderful all right Mary
Harrington thank you so much I really
enjoyed this
thank you Brett be well